[Música]
boa noite a todos hoje eu tô aqui pra
contar uma história uma história que
começou em 1984 em pocinhos uma pequena
cidade do interior do nordeste com cerca
de 18 mil habitantes em 1984 eu
participei da primeira feira de ciências
do colégio municipal padre galvão
naquele dia ela é e foi escolhido para a
nossa turma falar sobre plantas
medicinais
pra mim é um assunto que seria cairia
como uma luva afinal queria ser médica
já naquele tempo fui escolhida como a
líder da turma pra desenvolver o projeto
qual foi o resultado da feira de
ciências
nossa turma ficou em último lugar nesse
dia eu poderia muito bem ter desistido
mas eu parei pensei por que nossa turma
ficou em último lugar se era considerada
uma das melhores alunas do colégio o que
aconteceu e aí eu simplesmente ver que a
gente não tinha que eu não tinha
conseguido vender a ideia pra equipe
eu não tinha conseguido conquistar a
equipe que estava envolvida no projeto
e aí como vocês podem ver é de lá pra cá
eu melhorei tanto em pesquisa e também
eu acho a aparência e 2009 a gente
decide criar ipesc instituto de pesquisa
para o senhor joaquim amorim neto que
vem fazendo pesquisa desde esse período
o ips que foi criado por um grupo de
pesquisadores
a grande maioria doutores que tinha como
o principal objetivo fazer pesquisa
levando em consideração a assistência o
que ele a pesquisa poderia devolver para
os sujeitos que a gente chavão estávamos
pesquisando
com a equipe já formada e dessa vez um
equipe envolvida surge o ciclo do vírus
música vídeo surgiu no brasil o final
2014 início 2015 e quando ele surgiu não
despertou muita preocupação da saúde
pública porque ao contrário era uma
doença bem mais leve que a dengue dava
manchas vermelhas uma febre baixa e ela
passou desapercebida entrou chegou mas
não causou muita atenção até que surge
os primeiros casos de microcefalia em
setembro de 2015 eu fui procurado por
uma paciente para fazer outras
fotografias e essa paz e ti é ao
examinar o que eu vi esse exame é um
exame de ressonância mas fica mais fácil
vocês entenderem essa paciente tinha é
que uma ressonância de um feto com 29
semanas e o nosso bebê catarina maria
catarina ela tem uma redução do volume
do cérebro bem como a redução do volume
do cerebelo e é associada a esses
achados a gente encontrava a
calcificação esses três achados 19 anos
de profissão especialista em medicina
fetal eu nunca tinha visto
segurei na mão de conceição e diz que eu
não sabia o que tava acontecendo com o
bebê dela mas a gente descobrir
perguntei efe as perguntas comuns de
todo médico que você teve como foi sua
gravidez e ela por ser fisioterapeuta
nível superior
sabia que tenha tido zica quais tinham
sido os sintomas em que dia ela tenha
tido a partir daí eu fui em busca de
respostas
no dia seguinte um sábado o passeio é a
manhã fazendo pesquisa na internet sobre
música vírus e alterações fetais e
quando eu procurei no pub médico é o
maior banco de pesquisas em saúde
eu encontrei oito artigos falando sobre
música nenhum bola de zico e informações
fetais
hoje a gente vê a diferença em um ano
são mais de 1.500 artigos e esses
artigos aumentando a cada dia
mas como aquilo ia fazer para convencer
a comunidade científica eu a médica do
interior do nordeste
apesar de ter dois doutorados como
convenceria a comunidade científica do
brasil e do mundo em que a gente poderia
estar diante dos primeiros casos de
malformações fetais causada por um vírus
que já circulavam desde 1947 no mundo
e janeiro de 2015
e janeiro de 2016 desculpe
após uma longa investigação agente
coletou líquido amniótico dessas duas de
duas pacientes catarina maria foi uma e
e joão leva o segundo bebê que a gente
completou
esse material é a gente mandou pra fiel
cruza o rio de janeiro é em novembro de
2015 foi descoberto o ciclo do vírus
causava assim microcefalia foi
encontrada em grande quantidade do
líquido amniótico desses bebês em 2015 e
16 a gente publicou o primeiro artigo no
caso foi um dos primeiros dois primeiros
casos no mundo dedica o do zico vírus
estava relacionado a uma malformação
fetal
nesse artigo a gente já falava que a
microcefalia poderia ser só a ponta do
iceberg que existia poder existir muitas
outras coisas que a gente estava diante
de um novo agente teratogênico e que ele
precisava ser estudado
apesar da gente em 2 de janeiro de 2016
e conseguido publicar em uma das
principais revistas inclusive é certo
que bateu todos os recordes de acesso da
revista
só depois que uma revista que um grupo
de pesquisa do leste europeu publicou um
caso similar ao nosso é que o mundo foi
reconhecer e os envolvidos poderia
realmente está associada microcefalia
essas duas pacientes foram as nossas
duas primeiras
então aqui é catarina maria com os pais
e aqui jaz infelizmente sem seu bebê que
foi a óbito essas duas pacientes elas
foram parceiras elas entraram comigo em
tudo que eu sugeria então é só a são
paulo para servir por especialistas elas
coletaram líquido amniótico então elas
me acompanharam tudo eu sugeri elas
acreditaram diferentemente dos
pesquisadores e da academia elas
acreditaram que a gente estaria assim
diante de uma nova doença de novembro
quando a briga começou a falar fazer
ultrassonografia para o de ser aquele
momento mágico
todo mundo quando engravida toda mãe ela
já imagina o seu filho ela imagina não
só o filho estudando um filho se casando
o filho tendo filhos
o filho de preferência morrendo só
depois de 90 anos
é isso que a gente imagina um fundo para
os nossos filhos
então esse momento de ultra som que era
o momento que a os pais chegava para
saber o sexo para saber com quem parecia
para saber se o filho estava bem esse
momento se transformou num momento tenso
a sala de espera passou a ser um momento
de angústia e eu estava ali me sentia às
vezes como a juíza que é da sentença
seu filho está bem seu filho tem
microcefalia seu filho tem microcefalia
acha sobreviver são pequenas
fazer esse papel não era fácil porque eu
ter escolhido a obstetrícia porque eu
nunca gostei muito da morte
eu nunca gostei muito de chegar alguém
dá notícias tristes e agora estava
preparando com esse papel
e pior do que dar um diagnóstico a uma
mãe que o filho tem uma doença é não
saber o que dizer o que vai acontecer
com o filho dela quando tiver um ano
dois anos 20 anos
isso a gente não sabia então a nossa
equipe estava simplesmente segurar as
mãos e abraçar e dizer que elas não
estariam só então o meu papel que é
deveria terminar ali na sala de
ultrassom afinal de contas eu só faço
medicina fetal só vejo o feto
meu trabalho como pesquisador eu também
poderia ter na lei porque a partir
daquele momento senna altura do primeiro
artigo o meu nome já estava na história
da medicina
mas diante de tantas notícias ruins de
tanto olhar no olho dessas mães
a gente não poderia parar e eu tinha que
mudar essa história
essa é uma foto de uma mãe saindo do
corredor a minha sala depois que eu dei
a notícia eu vi você enxergar que ela
estava como destruidor de sonhos mas eu
tinha que dizer e que ajudar essas mães
que esse sonho poderia não ser um sonho
imaginado inicialmente
mas também poderia não ser um pesadelo
desde que elas não tivessem sons a
partir daí a gente começa a avaliar e
tentar descobrir mais coisas pra que
outras mães não passasse por essa
situação e aquelas duas mães que foram
parceiras
elas foram muito importantes não só para
a gente é o nosso grupo de pesquisa mas
foram importantes para o mundo e na
maioria das vezes elas não são
reconhecidas
jéssica teve o bebê em 40 semanas
ela ficou sabendo que o bebê dela tem
problema com 20 passou 20 semana
sabendo que o bebê não iria sobreviver
ela decidiu esquecer que o filho tinha
problemas e decidiu curtir a gravidez
quando chegou o dia do bebê nascer
esse foi um dos poucos momentos que ela
esteve com ele o bb subiu foi direto
para a uti
jéssica fez visitou o bebê segurou por
alguns minutos ele em tubarão o abraçou
depois desceu ao chegar no quarto recebe
novo telefonema dizendo que ela é que o
bebê tinha acabado de falecer que o
governo tenha falecido ela sobe mas mais
uma vez o ao berçário a uti nota joão
guilherme no colo
agora já sem tubo mas também sem vida
mas ainda quente e se despede do filho
nós como pesquisadores nós queremos
respostas
a gente queria muito um cérebro do bebê
mas como é que eu já teria coragem de
pedir uma mãe que passou por tudo isso
ela do joá se um cérebro
jéssica aos 23 anos proveniente do
interior da paraíba
olha próprias uma das pesquisadoras
fabiana e diz a missão de joão guilherme
foi trazer resposta ao mundo
eu quero do ao cérebro dele já que
nenhuma mãe passe pelo que eu estou
passando
joão guilherme vai cumprir a missão e o
cérebro de joão guilherme deu várias
respostas
muita gente que a gente sabe hoje a
gente deve essa mãe e essa criança
catarina maria foi a segunda criança que
sobreviveu catarina maria teve a grande
sorte de nascer ea mãe fisioterapeuta e
essa mãe é estimulou catarino marido de
manhã de tarde de noite todos os dias
catarina hoje ela tem um desenvolvimento
maior dentro do normal para a idade dela
e é isso que nos angustia meu ao mesmo
tempo que a gente fica feliz com o
desenvolvimento catarina maria
a gente vê que nem todas as outras mães
tiveram a sorte de ter uma mãe
fisioterapeuta ele tem acesso a isso
então eu digo sempre fazer a descoberta
é só ter sido criticada de tecido é
muito juve darão não foi a parte mais
difícil pra mim foi a parte mais fácil o
que fazer com essa descoberta é que tem
nos atormentar por um ano
essas mães elas foram tratados
inicialmente como números
hoje elas são tratadas como frasco de
sangue como um cérebro do seu filho
ouvido a orelha porque hoje os
pesquisadores querem publicar artigos e
chover nessas crianças a pena com apenas
como cobaias
essas mães que deram a resposta ao mundo
inteiro que talvez uma filha mia não vá
ter microcefalia que talvez os nossos
netos não tenham elas hoje não tem o que
deveria ter que é o direito a
assistência integral
essas mães elas fizeram a parte dela do
ano inclusive cérebro
nós do ipesc eu acho que a gente também
fez um pouquinho muito pouco ainda que é
fazer pesquisa sem nenhum recurso mas eu
acho que a gente tem que se perguntar e
nós o que é que nós estamos fazendo por
essas mães que nos deram tanto
obrigada
[Aplausos]